every single
thought we have or every sentence we
speak is an affirmation
and it's either positive or negative and
it's going out from us and it's creating
our experiences
however when we talk about doing
affirmations what we're talking about
is making definite
positive statements to create something
in our life or to remove something in
our life
you see if you stand there and say i
don't want this job or i don't want this
relationship or i don't want these hips
or i don't want whatever
that does not get you what you want
that's what i call fighting the negative
and it doesn't do anything but keep what
you have that you say you don't want
however if you start saying and doing
affirmations that i
have a wonderful new job or i have this
most
absolutely marvelous relationship then
you're beginning
to create what it is you do want
affirmations are like planting
seeds and if you think for a moment when
you put a seed in the ground you do not
get
instant tomato plant or instant
strawberries or instant oak tree
that seed goes in the ground and it has
to germinate
that's the first thing which means it
breaks open its little shell
and little roots begin to go down and it
gets nourishment from the earth
and only then does the first little
shoot come up through the ground
now when we're doing affirmations too
often people say well that is the
million dollars and they stomp on that
first little shoot they don't give it a
chance to grow
doing affirmations is like planting a
seed in the ground
and watering is it it is like repeating
your affirmations
and you just keep doing them and you
keep doing them and you keep doing them
and it doesn't matter whether you see
the results or you don't see the results
and sometimes it just takes time
and too many people will do affirmations
for two or three days and say see it
doesn't work
you know if
everything happens in the perfect time
space sequence and we want to trust that
and we want to know that
so if you begin to do affirmations for
yourself
and i think it's important that we do
that on a daily basis
decide what you want and begin to do
positive statements in present tense for
what you want
you never want to say i will have or i'm
going to have
because if you do that it keeps it in
the future
and remember if you say i have a
wonderful new apartment
and you're living in a dump it doesn't
mean that this is not a true statement
it means you are planting the seed
that will germinate and grow and become
the new apartment
so you just keep doing it no matter what
where you are
also if you're leaving a situation if
you're in a job you don't like if you're
in a relationship you don't like if
you're in a house you don't like
and you want something new begin to
bless with love
interesting bless with love where you
are
and and know that you're releasing your
current situation with love
if it's a job release it with love to
the next person who will be delighted to
have it
if it's an apartment do the same thing
if it's a relationship
release that person with love to
happiness
which is meaningful to them
and that leaves you free to create and
accept happiness that is meaningful to
you
to me i think enlightenment is letting
go
of all the things we believe that are
not
benefiting us us in life or there are
barriers to
our life to the good things in life and
to release them one by one and just
think
i don't have to believe that anymore or
do i want to believe that anymore
and making a conscious choice when we
can understand that
every single thing we believe has been a
choice
and it may or may not be true it can be
true for you and not for you
because it's your belief system and your
belief system and then i have my belief
system
i say a lot that may be true for you
it's not true for me i may not say that
out loud
but people are doing things they're
saying things and i think that to myself
a lot
and also it has nothing to do with me
whatever's going that has nothing to do
with me because i'm under
the law of my own consciousness this is
my pathway
and you have your pathway you have yours
everybody does
so we're all on a journey and i think
the more conscientious we are about it
and the more conscious choices we make
the better our journey is or the easier
or the swifter or that we get more
goodies or
we have better health for those of
people that have tried to change their
thinking but
seem to be stuck and can you give them
some advice to help them to be more
positive or
to get through well i don't think that
they've been trying and they're stuck
i think they just haven't tried because
if you will practice this
even a small amount it makes a
difference
i have a simple exercise i give
everybody and some people say oh that's
so stupid it's so silly
but i ask them to look in the mirror
especially first thing in the morning
and just look in their eyes and say
their name and say
i love you i really really love you
and this is enormously hard for most
people to do to begin with
but as you continue to do it it makes a
big difference
you see life loves you life really loves
you
but if you don't love yourself it's very
hard for life to bring you the goodies
because you've got this wall up so when
you can learn to love who you are
and that's the way you were born when
you were a little tiny baby and when i
say you i mean everybody listening to
this
we all adored ourselves we loved our
bodies we loved every part of ourselves
and then we started to listen to other
people who told us we weren't good
enough
or we didn't do it right or no no no
and so we decided that maybe we weren't
very good
and that's where we get all mixed up but
when we can get back to that point of
just
adoring this marvelous critter in here
uh then life says oh they've she's got
it she's got it
let's give her goodies and then the next
step is to be very grateful about it
when you're really grateful then they
want to give you more
remember little tiny babies when they're
born
they absolutely adore themselves and
they're totally open
and they're full of love they
express themselves freely they ask for
what they want
they love their bodies from the top of
the toe to the top of their head to the
tip of their toes
and every point in between including
their own feces which they'll gladly rub
all over their bodies because nobody's
taught them guilt and shame
they know how wonderful they are and
then somewhere along the line we get
this idea
that we're not good enough and we start
putting our tape
tape measures around our waistline to
tell us if we're acceptable
or we read magazines that say we have to
be a certain height or a certain weight
before we're acceptable
or we listen to the media that says we
have to use a certain deodorant before
we're acceptable
you know it just doesn't make sense
we are absolutely divine magnificent
expressions of life
all of us and like when we were in the
circle looking at each other
we each face is another unique
expression of god
and we're not supposed to be alike since
time began on this planet there have not
been
two snowflakes alike and there's
certainly not been two people alike
and we're always trying to be like
everybody else so we're acceptable
our uniqueness is what makes us
wonderful
so we want to love that and cherish it
and acknowledge it
you see if we really believe in our
uniqueness
and the wonder of each being then there
is no competition
and no comparison there can't be we're
just
different and we're meant to be
different and that's wonderful
a lot of people say i don't want to look
at the past my childhood was miserable
and i never want to think about it again
well then it's very important that you
start forgiving
because forgiveness sort of wipes the
slate clear
so that other things can come in yeah
yeah well the tapping
setup phrase right is even though i have
whatever the problem is i love and
forgive myself i accept myself
for myself where i love and approve of
myself yes right off if the
that's to me like the mirror work that i
do we'll have people do
also is to look in the mirror and look
into your own eyes and start with
something really simple but difficult
like i love you
i really really love you and most people
can't do that at all because it's just
too painful yeah they have all these
messages back here that says you're no
good and you can't be in
beside you your makeup isn't on right or
you forgot to shave today or something
you know
uh but once you can do that if you do it
over and over again for a while it's
like you connect
on a different level with that inner
child who's been waiting for years
and years and years for you to
acknowledge it and
something happens and i couldn't tell
you what it is
but i have learned that the people who
do their affirmations in front of a
mirror
make much quicker progress than other
people yeah i guess
it just it pushes through when life
calls us
that's when we have to answer people say
how did you do
everything that you did well i answered
the telephone and opened the mail
and did what it what was in front of me
and then life would give me something
else to do and something else to do
and it's interesting because it's now
been i think 25 years since i wrote
the second book you can heal your life
and
in that period of time
i that book alone has sold
40 million copies worldwide
and i feel i've always felt that i
didn't do anything
to promote it at all it's just life took
over and life said this book is going to
go to this country and this book is
going to go to this country
and go to this country and it's gone
many many places all over the world i
even have
two chinese versions there's the chinese
version of uh
traditional china and then there's the
chinese version of the taiwan which is
the new china
you never know where life is going to
take your work
and i think that it's important that you
don't go into it to say how much money
can i make oh i'm going to be rich i've
got to do this
because books don't make you that rich
but what they do is open the world to
you
and my thought has always been how can i
help the people
how can i help the people and i think if
you come from that point of view
it becomes a lot easier when i work with
people when i
workshops or classes or anything i
always try to get people just to open
their arms so that we can let the new
and remember this is the subconscious
mind and this is where we're holding
so this is saying nothing new will get
in so i always like to feel
that i'm open and receptive to new ideas
and i'm willing to learn and i'm willing
to change and i'm willing to grow
and sometimes i don't want to and
sometimes it hits areas that i
don't really care to change at the
moment and you know that's
always an area that i know is important
for me to work on
when we have a problem most of us go oh
panic panic god what are we going to do
but i have something that i try to get
people to say
when the minute there's a problem you
stop and you go all is well
all is well everything's working out for
my highest good
and out of this experience only good
will come
and i am safe and you do this
if it's a small thing i say it two or
three times if it's a bigger issue i
babble it incessantly but all is well
everything is working out for my highest
good out of
this situation only good will come
and i am safe now this gives
this quiets your inner turmoil down
long enough for the universe to find the
solution to the so-called problem
see when there's problems we don't have
to fix problems so much we need to fix
our thinking
and our attitude about how we respond to
them
and then you get less and less and when
the solution comes you say thank you
i say thank you many many many times of
the day
often not to anyone else i just you know
oh thank you that's so
wonderful thank you and it's uh
you know you find more and more things
to be thankful about we were i was
driving up today from
san diego and the wildflowers
on the hillsides are just beautiful this
year
and i was thinking i was so glad that i
had the opportunity to see them
because if i stayed down there i
wouldn't have with this drive which was
you know not a drive i particularly
wanted to make but it was gorgeous
one of the things that i think about the
work that i do and the work our company
does is that every product that we
sell or the problem that you get as a
gift from us
has the possibility to change the
quality of your life
to improve the quality of your life now
whether you actually take that
opportunity or not is up to you that's
freedom
but you have everything we give out can
help people
really improve the quality of their
lives and that
feels good i think that's important
because we do have a tendency in
in the society to just want to be fixed
right
and that's and that's it when i get over
this problem
this will be it i'll never have to deal
with anything you know a lot of us just
want to stop
when we hit a safe place yeah i mean
you've got a bit of money you've got
some nice friends you have a good house
to live and you're okay
you know and you think all right that's
fine i'm not going to touch
anything else but i have watched me and
how life
works for me is that when i get to a
really good level
then it's like okay now we're going to
deal with this thing yeah
and there's another thing and i've
learned to just say okay what do i do
yeah you know instead of leave me alone
don't talk to me
about that if you want to see the
awesome affirmations video we did with
bob proctor check it out right there
next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there how many times have you had
somebody say to you have you got a
minute but
you got a minute they don't want a
minute
i want you to think about that i read a
poem
one time